zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
es war ein schock am samstagabend
millionen schauten zu als beim endspiel
dänemark gegen finnland der fußballer
christian eriksen mitten auf dem platz
zusammenbrach
er hatte einen herzstillstand inzwischen
ist er wieder stabil sagen seine erste
und das lag unter anderem auch daran
dass sein mannschafts kollege
geistesgegenwärtig und sofort geholfen
hat und auch wusste was in dieser
situation zu tun ist und das hat bei
vielen von uns dazu geführt sich die
frage zu stellen wann eigentlich der
eigene letzte erste hilfe kurs war und
wie lange das schon her ist und es zeigt
auch dass viele von uns gar nicht
wüssten was sie in einer solchen
situation sinnvolles und richtiges und
schnelles tun müssten
ich komme gerade von der ersten hilfe
schulung bei lufthansa wir müssen das
einmal im jahr machen deswegen heute
könnte ich glaube ich würde mich auch
trauen aber es macht sinn dass immer mal
wieder aufzufrischen
zumal sich da auch dinge ändern ich weiß
ja nicht wie es dann im notfall wirklich
ist
wahrscheinlich würde ich versuchen ja
also wahrscheinlich wird das auch
hinkriegen aber ich glaube einfach die
hemmschwelle wer recht groß ist letzte
mal gemacht beim autoführerschein und
das ist jetzt schon sechs jahre liegt es
zurück also ich bin gar nicht mehr up to
date was das betrifft weiter ich würde
versuchen mit der atmung und so ein
bisschen hat man noch aus dem kopf waren
mehr drücken muss und wie man drücken
muss aber ich will zwar noch mal
angucken
ich musste überlegen ob ich noch könnte
und vermutlich den rhytmus kriegt noch
so halbwegs sind aber wie viele schläge
das genau sind bis man atmen muss und
dass man auch irgendwie den kopf nach
hinten streckt das kriegt noch hin aber
das war es dann auch schon sehr viele
von uns wissen noch so ein bisschen
dunkel wie es geht aber so richtig
eigentlich nicht zumindest weniger haben
wir gerade gesehen
wir sprechen darüber heute mit doktor
aimo martens er ist kardiologe und
oberarzt an der tu in münchen schönen
guten abend herr dr martens
herr dr martens sie haben die szene
sicherlich auch verfolgt am samstag und
da fragt man sich natürlich war es
einfach glück
dass der dänische mannschaftskapitän in
dem moment einfach genau gewusst hat was
er tun muss stabile seitenlage
herstellen gucken dass der spieler seine
eigene zunge nicht verschluckt und dass
dann die ärzte so schnell an ort und
stelle waren und auch richtig gehandelt
haben
ja ich glaube das ist auf jeden fall
glück dass wir sind so einem setting
passiert wo viele drum herum stehen und
wo wahrscheinlich auch einige geschulte
und die ärzte direkt dabei waren das ist
sicherlich nicht immer der fall oder
fast niemals wir haben meistens das
problem dass weder die lange gebraucht
wird bis jemand überhaupt zur hilfe
kommt und dass dann nicht immer ganz
klar ist wie soll man helfen
wie muss man jetzt weiter verfahren so
das glaube ich dass wenn es zu so einer
schweren situation kommt sicher der
beste standort damit sowas passiert
außer ist es direkt im krankenhaus
wir beschäftigen uns gleich ausführlich
noch mal mit der frage was genau muss
ich denn dann machen in der situation
einen zuschauer namens rush hour
schreibt über youtube glaube zwei mal
pusten und 30 mal drücken
sie werden uns gleich nochmal genau
erklären wie wie wir uns verhalten
müssen in der situation ich würde nur
gern erst noch mal bei den patienten
selber bleiben
ausgehend von der situation am samstag
die wir da gesehen haben sind denn
sportler gerade hochleistungssportler
besonders gefährdet also grundsätzlich
muss man sagen dass sport natürlich was
ist was einen davor schützt dass man am
herzen probleme bekommt normalerweise
natürlich ist hochleistungssport eine
andere kategorie
und deswegen empfehlen wir wie das auch
in solchen mannschaften gemacht wird
allen hochleistungssportlern sich gerade
durch kardiologisch durchchecken zu
lassen
insgesamt sind patienten die sport
treiben normalerweise nicht unseren
hohen risiko aber so eine massive
anstrengung wie so ein fußballspiel kann
natürlich solche ereignisse provozieren
wenn man dazu eine veranlagung mitbringt
und dann gibt es verschiedene
veranlagungen das häufigste ist sich
einig
oder herzerkrankungen also sowas worüber
man den klassischen herzinfarkt
entwickelt aber es gibt auch genetische
veranlagungen die man nicht immer
vorhersehen kann ein wichtiges thema
schreibt auch der zuschauer nur lesen
gerade über youtube und deshalb sprechen
wir natürlich auch darüber wenn das ein
dramatischer anlass ist sozusagen aber
es ist ein thema was viele von uns
betrifft und was fast jeden treffen kann
wie sie gerade gesagt haben wir haben
noch ein paar zahlen dazu
zusammengestellt jan frederik fischer
hat das für uns gemacht hilfe eine
person liegt am boden jede minute zählt
doch wie leistet man jetzt eigentlich
erste hilfe als aller erstes sollte man
sich einen überblick verschaffen und
überprüfen ob die betroffene person noch
ansprechbar ist ist dies nicht der fall
sollte zunächst der kopf überstreckt
werden so dass die zunge den atem weg
frei macht direkt danach muss die atmung
überprüft werden ist diese noch
vorhanden sollte die personen eine
stabile seitenlage gebracht werden
dann heißt es hilfe holen und zwar über
die notrufnummer 112 atmet die person
nicht mehr sollte direkt der notruf
gewählt und im anschluss eine
wiederbelebung durchgeführt werden dafür
die hände auf den unteren brustkorb
auflegen und mit dem handballen 30 mal
kräftig drücken im rhythmus des liedes
staying alive als nächsten schritt die
nase zu halten und den patienten beatmen
bis rettungskräfte eintreffen sollte der
vorgang wiederholt werden
[Musik]
das war schon die anleitung wir sehen
hier nämlich in der community sind die
fragen die ganz praktischen fragen sehr
sehr viele und die leute wollen einfach
wissen was man in der situation tun muss
deshalb nehmen wir das einfach mal
zuerst raus und vertiefen das bevor wir
dann über die sprechen die besonders
gefährdet sind einen solchen
herzstillstand zu bekommen und 1 möchte
ich gerne aufgreifen was auch über die
community angesprochen wird nämlich das
was einen erstmal bis hin zum schmunzeln
bringt sie schreibt auch über youtube hh
stayalive kein witz zum beat von den bee
gees kann man gut wieder
und das ist ja tatsächlich so wie wir
gerade auch gesehen haben hat dr martens
können sie nochmal erklären warum es
geht um die frequenz in der man das herz
wieder beleben muss damit ein
vernünftiger chrysler damit das blut
gepumpt wird
und da wollen wir in den leitlinien oder
hat sich in studien gezeigt dass man
ungefähr einen puls von um die 100
erreichen muss damit man wenn man von
außen auf den menschen drauf drückt auch
einen einigermaßen sinnvollen blutdruck
aufbaut um den menschen quasi in so
einem basis modus am leben zu erhalten
und da hat sich über jahre gezeigt das
lied ist der beste rhythmus dafür
ungefähr mit 100 zu drücken was ihr ein
bisschen schneller ist als die normale
herzfrequenz
sie sind selbst auch notarzt einsätze
gefahren haben sie selber auch dieses
lied für sich gewählt oder haben sie zum
beispiel helene fischer gibt glaube ich
auch oder haben sie ein anderes was bei
ihnen besonders gut funktioniert hat
also tatsächlich bin ich mit stay alive
groß geworden sozusagen aber die also
eben der in der rettungsmedizin aber die
modernen geräte im notarzt wagen geben
eine mit seinem hit stufen metronom ton
auch einen takt vor an dem man sich
halten kann also es ein bisschen
langweiliger geworden
dann bleiben wir beim faktor zeit was
passiert wenn das herz stillsteht und
wie schnell muss es dann gehen bis
wieder aktion kommt genauso wenn wir uns
so was wie beim fußballspiel angucken
dann entsteht das herz an die 100
prozent stellt und dann meistens
entsteht eine rhythmusstörung die heißt
kammerflimmern
das ist wichtig um später zu verstehen
warum man definiert und kammerflimmern
ist eine ganz schnelle ungerichtete
erregung im herzen und die führen dazu
dass das herz nur noch so zittert und
nicht mehr vernünftig schlagen kann und
dieses zittern lässt das blut im kreis
im herzen und auch im ganzen kreis dorf
komplett stillstehen
und wenn das passiert wird das gehirn
und der ganze körper nicht mehr
durchblutet aber das gehirn dass das
wichtigste das hält es nur am aller
kürzesten aus nach ungefähr zwei minuten
still stehen dem herz stirbt im gehirn
das ab und deswegen ist es so extrem
wichtig dass man schnell reagiert wenn
man sieht dass jemand umgefallen ist
das heißt man muss dann schnell handeln
und das ist ja genau das problem dass
viele erstmal zögern zu handeln auch aus
sorge was falsch zu machen oder nicht
das richtige zu tun was könnte man denn
falsch machen gibt es überhaupt
irgendwas was man da falsch machen kann
also da kann man alle entbinden
sozusagen falsch machen kann man in so
einer situation eigentlich gar nichts
das wichtigste ist dass man den
rettungsdienst ruf dass man überhaupt
was macht und dass man beginnt mit den
maßnahmen die sie vorhin schon so schön
gezeigt haben und in den letzten jahren
ist es so dass unsere fachgesellschaften
sogar dazu übergegangen sind dass man
laien also jedem von den zuschauern die
eine wiederbelebungs situation sehen
sogar empfiehlt gar nicht mehr zu
beatmen sondern einfach nur zu drücken
im biet des liedes weil dadurch genug
sauerstoff hin und her pendelt und der
mann festgestellt hat dass die größte
abschreckung natürlich was man sich
vorstellen kann
von der mund zu nase bzw den mund zu
mund beatmung ausgehen und so empfiehlt
man wenn man was macht notruf absetzen
und dann einfach anfangen mit den
wiederbelebungsmaßnahmen einfach auf den
thorax drücken mit gestreckten armen so
wie sie es allemal gelernt haben dh da
muss ich noch mal nachfragen 30 mal
drücken zwei mal pusten würden sie sagen
drücken reicht posten muss gar nicht
sagen
für jeden der sich damit auskennt der
das gelernt hat und der sich das zutraut
ist das allerbeste 30 mal drücken und
zweimal waren genauso machen wie es auch
aber wir empfehlen bevor man gar nichts
macht einfach nur herzdruckmassage bis
der rettungsdienst kommt ist immer noch
besser als gar nichts machen viele
fragen kann ich zum beispiel rippen
brechen kann nicht was kaputt machen
dabei wenn ich fest auf den auf den
oberkörper drücke und auch bei kindern
zum beispiel hat man ja auch besondere
angst etwas falsch zu machen nochmal die
frage auch wenn sie so doof ist aber
kann ich irgendwas kaputt machen also
man kann jeder wieder überlegungen
rippen brechen denn das ist ein stück
weit normal das passiert uns auch das
ist aber harmlos
eine rippe verheilt wieder und dass das
soll nicht daran hindern das mann
reanimiert also da passiert wirklich
nichts dass man dazu tief ein drückt das
ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich die druck
tiefe sollte ungefähr fünf bis sechs
zentimeter sein wenn man das noch nie
gemacht hat drückt man zuerst auf jeden
fall erstmal zu wenig und da kann man
sich langsam rantasten das auch kein
problem hauptsache man beginnt kinder
reanimationen sind natürlich noch mal
was ganz anderes
das ist das was wir auch in der breiten
ersten hilfe nur so gering schulen aber
auch da sollte man versuchen je nach
alter des kindes mit maßnahmen zu
beginnen zum beispiel mit einer
seitenlage
da ist es häufig so dass die atemwege
verlegt sind also da muss man gucken hat
das kind irgendetwas verschluckt und
wenn man sich zutraut kann man auch mit
den wiederbelebungsmaßnahmen da beginnen
oder sollte man auf taucht die frage
nach defibrillatoren auf ist dass ein
ersatz ist das ein zusatz würden sie das
vorziehen sollte man das eher benutzen
und gucken wo ist in der nähe so ein
gerät statt auf die eigenen hände zu
vertrauen
können sie das einordnen ja deswegen
hatte ich im vorhinein kurz angerissen
wie das elektrisch funktioniert dass das
herz stehen bleibt nämlich mit diesem
kammerflimmern mit dieser ungerechten
elektrischen aktivität und die kann man
mit einem defibrillator durchbrechen
damit kann man den patienten wieder ins
leben zurückholen allerdings ist es so
dass das zwei verschiedene mechanismen
sind das eine ist die elektrik das
andere ist die mechanik des herzens also
sie müssen in jedem fall wieder beleben
mechanisch um den kreislauf in gang zu
halten und wenn der patient umgefallen
ist dann sollte man immer erst einmal
mechanisch rädern realisieren also mit
der herzdruckmassage beginnen damit
erstmal überhaupt einen kreislauf wieder
in gang kommt und das gehirn wieder
durchblutet wird dann kann man sich
darum kümmern auch einen defibrillator
irgendwo in der nähe ist also zum
beispiel einen anderen passanten
schicken oder
fragen ob irgendwo was hängt und das
dann ran holen lassen
derjenige der patienten ist und schon
mit einer reanimation begonnen hat der
sollte immer weiter reanimieren damit
das nicht unterbrochen wird wenn dann so
ein gerät gefunden ist dann kann man das
aufkleben 1 sie auf das brustbein 1 an
die seite sofort so zwei aufklebern das
sehr gut erklärt in allen diesen geräten
und dann macht das gerät alles von
selber aber da muss man mindestens einen
zyklus 30 mal gedrückt haben
und dann kann man da auch die rhythmus
analyse drücken und dann wird ein
sogenannter elektroschock abgegeben wenn
das nötig ist und der durchbricht dann
das kammerflimmern und dann muss man
trotzdem noch weiter mechanisch
reanimieren bis das herz wieder richtig
anfängt zu schlagen das dauert auch dann
noch ein bisschen
das ist aber der vorteil wenn das gerät
einmal angeschlossen ist dann erklärt
dass auch noch nebenbei haben sie
eigentlich erfahrungswert oder wissen
sie zufällig ob die leute eher zögern
defibrillatoren einzusetzen oder ob sie
eher darauf vertrauen weil sie glauben
ich nutze das gerät ist kann es besser
als ich oder haben viele hemmungen zu
sagen oder muss ich das eigentlich von
der wand und ich weiß nicht wie es
handhaben soll also was wie wird es
eingesetzt was ist ihre ihr wissen
darüber ja unsere kollegen vom institut
für notfallmedizin haben dass hier in
münchen schon mal ganz gut aus gewertet
dass ich das zum glück über die jahre
wir haben jetzt schon über 20 jahre die
im reaktor 1 in münchen in der u bahn im
einsatz
und dass ich das zum glück über die
jahre deutlich verbessert hat also dass
die akzeptanz unter denen bürger gut
gestiegen ist und dass die mehr mehr
eingesetzt werden aber genau diese
vorbehalte die sie nennen sind da die
menschen denken sie können mit dem gerät
ein fälschlicherweise einen schock
abgeben das ist aber nahezu unmöglich
das hat ein computer algorithmus drin
der sowas verhindert so dass da schon
gewisse vorbehalte sind und dass auch
unser job der aufklärung zu sagen sie
können mit der kiste nichts falsch
machen auf jeden fall aufkleben und mal
einmal drauf drücken dann macht das
gerät alles von allein und wenn das
nicht geschehe brillieren kann dann gibt
es auch die anweisung weiter mit der
herzdruckmassage zu machen
wir bekommen hier auch ein paar
kommentare von userinnen und usern die
berichten was sie selbst für erfahrungen
gemacht
haben und an der stelle auch noch mal
der aufruf schreibt uns eure erfahrungen
was ihr mit erste hilfe situationen für
dinge erlebt hat schreibt es in die
kommentarspalten oder auch an die
bekannte e mail adresse wir freuen uns
sehr über eure berichte karin harbeck
schreibt ich bin ehemalige
krankenschwester und habe vier menschen
reanimiert auch eine junge frau habe
früher auf der kardiologie gearbeitet
und viele haben es nicht geschafft erste
hilfe ist ganz wichtig auch für kleine
kinder
und dazu gibt es eine anschlussfrage von
sarah was ist denn bei der ersten hilfe
von kindern besonders zu beachten welche
unterschiede gibt es da also reanimation
von den kindern unterscheidet sich
natürlich von erwachsenen
anhand der größe des kindes das wie
gesagt das häufigste bei kindern warum
die reanimation flächig wurden oder
werden ist das die eine verlegung der
atemwege haben das haben sie ja vorhin
auch bei den erwachsenen gezeigt die
erste inspektion wenn man beim beim
patienten ankommt ist sind die atemwege
frei
das geht beim erwachsenen so ein
bisschen den kopf überstrecken das macht
man mit kindern nicht ganz so stark man
sollte man auf jeden fall in den mund
schauen ob da irgendwo was drin ist wenn
nicht wenn nicht sichtbar ist dann
beginnt man da auch mit
wiederbelebungsmaßnahmen mittlerweile
machen wieder auf 30 zu 28 man das
entweder mit zwei fingern drückt so
ungefähr ein drittel des thorax ein oder
man kann das bei kleinen babys auch
zwischen in die hand nehmen so zu sagen
und da auch 30 zu zwei drücken und bei
den kindern empfehlen wir schon eine
leichte mund zu nase beziehungsweise
mund-zu-mund-beatmung je nach alter des
kindes zu machen weil eben sauerstoff
das häufigste problem ist dass das
mangel an sauerstoff
es gibt wenige wirklich weniger ursachen
die auch im kindesalter einen
plötzlichen herztod mit sich bringen so
angeborene rhythmusstörung ist es
wirklich sehr sehr selten
wichtig ist also wenn man ihnen
aufmerksam zugehört und auch wenn man
hier in dem chat verfolgt dass man
überhaupt etwas macht dass man handelt
in der situation dietmar dunkel schreibt
über youtube vor allem wenn einer in not
ist sofort hin und gucken was zu machen
ist und nicht warten
ob einer schneller ist jeder einzelne
kann immer etwas tun ganz wichtiges
statement von dietmar dunkel an dieser
stelle und wir weisen auch noch mal
daraufhin jeder der nicht erste hilfe
leistet macht sich strafbar § 323 c
strafgesetzbuch darin ist die pflicht
zur ersten hilfe in deutschland
verankert wer bei unglücksfällen nicht
hilfe leistet obwohl dies erforderlich
ist wird mit freiheitsstrafe mit bis zu
einem jahr oder mit geldstrafe bestraft
auch das ist vielleicht wichtig noch mal
zu erwähnen
dann blicken wir mal darauf wie viele
leute in deutschland denn helfen in
diesen situationen und wenn man sich da
den internationalen vergleich anguckt
dann stellt man fest in anderen ländern
sind die menschen sehr viel
bereitwilliger oder vielleicht
mutwilliger erste hilfe zu leisten in
skandinavien zum beispiel wie erklären
sie sich das ja also ich glaube das ist
auch unsere erfahrung wirklich sagen was
ist es in den letzten jahren deutlich
besser geworden es wird mehr geholfen
die ausbildung ist glaube ich breiter
geworden aber in vielen anderen ländern
in europa gibt es nicht pflicht oder
zumindest eine bessere möglichkeit sich
fit zu halten im bereich der
wiederbelebung oder überhaupt der ersten
hilfe das ist schon was was wir in
deutschland vielleicht etwas
vernachlässigen wie wir unsere mitbürger
und mitbürgerinnen weiter ausbilden
neben der einmaligen ausbildung im
bereich des führerscheins oder
vielleicht beruflichen ausbildung viele
unternehmen haben wir mein spieler auch
schon gehört machen das einmal jährlich
oder zu mindestens alle zwei jahre
aber da sind die scandinavia uns schon
über jahre voraus die sind viel besser
in der breitenausbildung vielleicht
liegt es natürlich auch daran dass die
mir sehr strukturschwache region oder
schon sehr strukturschwache regionen
haben wo der rettungsdienst nicht ganz
so schnell ist und die deswegen besser
in die breite gehen wupper blick
schreibt zu dem thema mein kurs erst 42
jahre her und ich hätte echt probleme
bei einer wiederbelebung darin bin darum
bin ich der meinung ist müsste eine
auffrischung des kurses geben alle drei
bis vier jahre wäre nicht schlecht das
geht also in die richtung die sie gerade
angesprochen haben
und ich würde gerne noch nach der schule
fragen warum kann man nicht wie zum
beispiel in schweden oder finnland schon
in der grundschule oder von mir aus in
der sechsten siebten klasse das als teil
des unterrichts verpflichtend mit
einbauen denn wir alle wissen was man
als kind gelernt hat es vielleicht so
ein bisschen wie das skifahren oder oder
schwimmen
das verlernt man nicht mehr genau
absolut also ich selber unterstütze hier
einige kurse wo es um so schulsanitäter
ausbildung in der region hier um münchen
herum geht das ist auch unsere meinung
also natürlich können sie das jetzt
nicht vielleicht in der ersten klasse
anfangen aber also jugendliche mit 15 16
können das problemlos lernen sicherlich
auch sogar noch jüngere ich kenne selber
kinder die ihre eltern reanimiert haben
also die können das auch ohne große
anleitung alleine durch anleitung der
rettungsleitstelle
das wäre absolut sinnvoll dass in der
breite in der schule an
können sie sich erklären warum das nicht
der fall ist also man ist ja nicht so
kompliziert
irgendwie haben wir immer noch eine
abneigung gegen dieses verfahren wir
kämpfen ja schon mit verschiedenen
fachgesellschaften schon lange dagegen
dass das breite eingeführt wird uns
helfen sehr gut stiftungen die das
anbieten für leute die darauf lust haben
sie kämpfen dafür dass es breite
eingeführt wir kämpfen dafür dass es
breite eingeführt wird also dagegen dass
es das ist so schlecht
ausgerollt ist sozusagen und es gibt ein
paar stiftungen wie die herzstiftung und
auch andere die da in der breite aktiv
sind und auch werbung machen und leute
ansprechen aber es wäre eben viel
einfacher das schon früh an zu bringen
ich glaube es sind vielleicht ja doch
auch aversionen in der politik wie man
damit umgehen soll mit so einem thema es
ist sehr schade also wir können nur alle
mithelfen dass man das früh und breit
macht ein kollege von ihnen sagt als
todesursache sei der plötzliche herz
kreislauf tisch dann fast so häufig wie
alle krebserkrankungen zusammen
und wenn alle in deutschland wüssten wie
wiederbelebung funktioniert dann könnten
wir jedes jahr zusätzlich 10.000
menschen leben bei uns retten würden sie
das so unterschreiben
ja das kommen ist sehr regional sehr
unterschiedlich wir selber in unserer
gruppe beschäftigen uns mit der
häufigkeit von plötzlichem herz so wie
er denken wir sind ungefähr so bei 180
fällen pro 100.000 einwohner pro jahr
also sind man auch ein häufiges ereignis
natürlich ist immer noch das häufigste
koronare herzerkrankung aber das
wichtigste ist dass man schnell reagiert
und absolut wenn mehr reagiert würde
dann hörten die patienten das besser
überleben absolut also wir werden
natürlich ist er der anteil von den
patienten die gut aus dem krankenhaus
wieder rauskommen
in den letzten jahren gestiegen aber es
immer noch sehr sehr gering
gunnar dresen schreibt über facebook
seine erfahrung manchmal kann es so
simpel sein wenn man weiß was zu tun ist
sein müsste ich habe vermutlich einer
kollegin mal das leben gerettet weil
meine vermutung eines schlaganfalls
richtig war und der sofortige notruf und
den fahrstuhl für die rettungskräfte zu
blockieren
die beste entscheidung war und alle
anderen drum herum nur in panik
rumgeeiert haben
vielen dank herr griesel für diesen
bericht das ist aber natürlich genau das
was in der situation so schwierig ist
die situation zu erfassen dann aktiv zu
werden und dann auch noch
geistesgegenwärtig die richtigen dinge
zu tun kann man das irgendwie trainieren
kann man versuchen sich darauf
vorzubereiten dass man in so einer
situation das richtige tut haben sie der
tipps
also natürlich gehe sind solche
situationen sehr individuell und ich
glaube alles kann man nicht trainieren
aber einen gewissen teil natürlich schon
also das wichtigste ist glaube ich zu
erkennen okay da geht es jemandem
schlecht und das ist schon eine
relevante problematik und dann muss man
den notruf absetzen das ist mal das
allerwichtigste und das andere ist schon
dass auch wir hier mit unternehmen
zusammen so notfallpläne entwickelt wo
tatsächlich genau solche sachen geplant
werden wie kann man den aufzug anhalten
wie kann man zum beispiel meinem
unternehmen wie bmw den richtigen
ausgang bezeichnen aber meist ist es so
dass die kollegen auf der leitstelle mit
denen man telefoniert wenn der notar
notruf abgesetzt wird sie darauf
hinweisen und diese relevanten dinge
abfragen und sie animieren den weg für
die rettungskräfte frei zu machen oder
auch mit der wiederbelebung zu beginnen
dann blicken wir jetzt mal auf die dies
trifft und steigen ein mit einer frage
oder mit einem statement von frank
mühlbauer der auch über mühlbayer
entschuldigung der über facebook
schreibt wie kann man sich vor einem
herzstillstand schützen
denn wenn man alleine lebt dann stirbt
man wenn man einen herzstillstand hat
und das finde ich insofern interessant
weil herr mühlbayer was anspricht was
glaube ich tatsächlich auch der realität
und den zahlen entspricht denn dass man
einen herzstillstand hat wie der
fußballer ericsson vor einem
millionenpublikum das ist natürlich
absolut außergewöhnlich und auch dass
das im öffentlichen raum stattfindet ist
äußerst selten
denn die meisten herzstillstände
passieren tatsächlich zu hause und dann
mutmaßlich auch wenn gar niemand dabei
ist richtig und das ist absolut korrekt
auch das haben wir uns schon häufiger
angeschaut wie die zeit verteilung auch
die örtliche verteilung ist und die
meisten patienten denen passiert so was
zu hause und leider sind viele auch
alleine deswegen hat man früher gedacht
der morgen ist der häufigste zeitpunkt
für einen plötzlichen herztod weil die
patienten morgens gefunden wurden aber
das ist natürlich nicht so das sind
nicht nur daran dass morgens häufig
irgendwelche pflegekräfte oder so zu
besuch kommen also wie man sich davor
schützen kann ist die nächste frage
das ist nicht ganz so einfach ich glaube
das wichtigste ist dass man ab einem
gewissen alter so ungefähr
60 immer mal wieder zu
kontrolluntersuchungen zum hausarzt oder
dann noch zum kardiologen geht wenn man
in der familie fälle von plötzlichem
herztod hat insbesondere bei jüngeren
patienten so wie jetzt beim fußballspiel
dann sollte man sich mit der gesamten
familie mal beim kardiologen
durchchecken lassen es gibt auch da
hinweise dass sowas auch mal in der
familie liegen kann also das ist schon
wichtig da ein bisschen aufmerksam zu
sein und was macht der kardiologe dann
der guckt sich vor allen dingen so
bausteine drumherum wie es der zucker
eingestellt wie es der blutung
eingestellt so was an und versucht sie
dann zu beraten ob sich ein risiko haben
oder nicht dann blicken wir mal auf die
gruppen die vielleicht besondere risiko
haben oder andere nicht jan frederick
fisher hat zusammengestellt wie die
zahlen so aussehen ein plötzlicher
herzstillstand unerwartet jeden kann es
treffen egal wann egal wo eine schnelle
reaktion lebensrettend doch wie oft
kommt es zu solchen notfällen antworten
liefern die daten des deutschen
reanimation registers sie umfassen knapp
30 millionen einwohner hochgerechnet
retteten einsatzkräfte im vergangenen
jahr rund 60.000 patienten nach einem
herz-kreislauf-stillstand insgesamt
betroffen waren mehr männer ganze 66,4
prozent frauen waren zu rund einem
drittel betroffen
das durchschnittsalter der patienten war
mit 70 jahren sehr hoch zum vergleich
nur 1,6 prozent waren noch nicht
volljährig 31,4 prozent waren älter als
doch wo fanden die reanimation stadt vor
allem im häuslichen umfeld 64,1 prozent
in der öffentlichkeit waren es hingegen
nur 18
wichtig in mehr als 35 prozent der fälle
haben laien die reanimation durchgeführt
denn bis professionelle einsatzkräfte
vor ort sein können vergehen minuten
zuletzt waren es nach einem notruf mehr
als 7 an der stelle ein sehr nahegehen
der kommentar von einem user namens
dennis br punkt mein vater konnte noch
selbst den notruf wählen als er einen
herzinfarkt bekommen hat hat leider
nichts mehr gebracht und danke auch für
die vielen beileidsbekundungen die in
der community an dennis geäußert werden
vielen dank für diesen sehr persönlichen
beitrag zu der sendung und noch mal an
sie die frage herr dr martens wie viele
menschen überleben denn einen solchen
herzstillstand und wie viele menschen
die wiederbelebt wurden können denn
danach wieder so ins leben zurückkehren
wie sie es vorher gekannt haben
ja das ist leider immer noch
erschreckend
die zahlen haben sich deutlich gebessert
aber wenn man sich jetzt in münchen dass
zum beispiel anschauen überleben
ungefähr 25 prozent der patienten die
reanimiert werden außerhalb der klinik
also irgendwo auf der straße oder zu
hause überhaupt dieses ganze ereignis
also werden noch lebend in die klinik
eingeliefert und können diese in
irgendeiner form lebend verlassen und
die wichtige frage dabei ist wie lange
wurden diese patienten nicht reanimiert
also wie lange haben die zu hause oder
auf der straße gelegen bevor
wiederbelebungsmaßnahmen eingeleitet
wurden das hatte ich vorhin schon gesagt
weil das gehirn ist da sehr sehr heikel
nach kurzer zeit stirbt bereits was ab
und so dass viele patienten die ins
krankenhaus kommen
nachher mit schweren neurologischen
schäden leider entlassen werden müssen
das hat sich deutlich gebessert in den
letzten jahren aber es sind insgesamt so
überstehen vielleicht zehn prozent der
patienten das so dass sie danach wieder
im normalen leben teilnehmen können
das ist sehr sehr wenig im
länderdurchschnitt ist es in anderen
ländern ähnlich haben der auch in
deutschland regional sehr
unterschiedlich kommen sie in ländliche
regionen kann das noch schlechter werden
das heißt also nochmal je schneller
desto besser nicht nachdenken sondern
einfach schnell was machen denn die zeit
ist der hauptfeind in dem moment je
länger die zeit verrinnt desto weniger
aussichten auf erfolg hat die hilfe
absolut also 100 prozent zustimmung das
ist das allerwichtigste und deswegen
kann man nur empfehlen
hauptsache was machen und deswegen auch
keine angst vor der beatmung einfach
herzdruckmassage machen wenn man sich
die beatmung nicht zutraut oder das
gelernte zu lange her ist damit hat man
zumindestens einen basis kreislauf
aufrecht erhalten bis der rettungsdienst
kommt und sie haben es in ihrem beitrag
gezeigt gerade in den zentren ist es
sogar noch schneller die einsatzzeit
sieben minuten im durchschnitt
das ist ja schon relativ schnell aber
nach zwei minuten ist das gehirn schon
irreversibel geschädigt also es gibt
immer noch ein großes gelb dazwischen wo
jemand vor ort was machen muss ich sehe
hier in der community ist viel zuspruch
dafür dass dieses dass das erste hilfe
training regelmäßiger und auch
verpflichtend durchgeführt werden soll
das tor metro schreibt über youtube auch
regelmäßiges reanimation training sollte
zur pflicht werden noch eine frage zum
abschluss wie verarbeitet man eine
solche situation wenn man als helfer
versucht hat jemanden das leben zu
retten
je nachdem wie diese situation natürlich
auch war gibt es im nachhinein hilfe wie
man damit umgeht denn das ist ja eine
grenzerfahrung absolut also ich glaube
auf der einen seite muss man sehen wenn
man nicht geholfen hätte wäre der
patient mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit verstorben das heißt
es immer was schönes zu helfen weil man
gibt dem patienten eine chance überhaupt
ein krankenhaus zu erreichen also das
muss man glaube ich über alles drüber
stellen und ansonsten ist es schon so
dass wir mittlerweile in allen großen
städten und auch in den landkreisen
sogenannte kriseninterventionsteams
haben die sich auch den helfern annehmen
und die dann auch später kontakt sind
sollte es zu problemen danach kommen
oder sollten die die refa noch mal
fragen haben oder wirklich auch es gibt
tatsächlich auch bei uns in der
psychosomatik ist also eine ambulante
anlaufstellen gibt es einfach
anlaufstellen und dass die patienten
dann immer weiterhin noch davon träumen
oder sowas aber das ist sehr sehr selten
die meisten am er die positives feedback
sagt dr martens kardiologe und oberarzt
an der tu in münchen vielen dank herr
doktor martens dass sie an diesem abend
bei uns waren und dieses thema sehr
praktisch auch mit vielen tipps mit
denen man was anfangen kann mit uns
besprochen haben vielen herzlichen dank
vielen meiner seite und ich bedanke mich
bei ihnen und euch fürs zuschauen und
mitmachen und schließe mit einem
kommentar von gunther nochmal über
youtube cool dass ihr live streams über
wichtige themen macht das freut uns
vielen dank dafür
und ich sage tschüss einen schönen abend
noch und bis zum nächsten mal